on this Thursday night preparing for a
punishing storm the dire warnings as
Atlantic Canada braces for Hurricane
Fiona they're saying that we might be
right in the center of it major prisoner
swamp the happy homecoming for Ukrainian
troops I want to thank everyone
especially plus more Russians plot an
exit strategy Ontario confidential the
critical information that Province won't
share with child welfare agencies and
families Global News investigates and a
Family Feud turns political that could
create some challenges two brothers
estranged for three decades vying for
one mayoral seat
[Music]
okay
mobile National with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha
good evening and thanks for joining us
hurricane Fiona is on track to blast
through Atlantic Canada before the storm
is expected to make landfall on Saturday
morning people in Nova Scotia will feel
it coming the Canadian Hurricane Center
says winds will start picking up
overnight Friday before it hits the
province officials are preparing for
flooding Storm surges and power outages
Ross Lord is in Cape Breton tonight
where people are preparing for the worst
Ross
only through the waiting wondering and
worrying is a regular part of life here
in Atlanta Canada during Hurricane
Season but forecasters say there's
nothing regular about Fiona and they're
wanting people not to underestimate
what's coming
Danny wood is taking precautions tying
down his belongings stocking up and
gasoline in case Fiona causes prolonged
power outages they're saying that we
might be right in the center of it give
or take a few miles so
we're just going to see what happens and
take it from there heeding the warnings
from forecasters who say Fiona might
make landfall in Atlanta Canada as a
post-tropical storm a term that's less
ominous than hurricane but the reality
is its impact could be even more
devastating because a separate weather
system is likely to merge with Fiona
leading to widespread impact
the two features are expected to
interact uh resulting in an extremely
strong and dangerous storm uh for
Eastern Canada
um starting late uh Friday into Saturday
the preparations are ramping up we don't
haul our boats out until uh another week
and a half or so so we have no choice
but to try to secure things power
utilities and emergency planners say
they are ready to respond but factors
they can't control like trees in full
foliage more vulnerable to being toppled
over or compounding everyone's anxiety
nithu Ross Lord in Port Hawkesbury Nova
Scotia thanks Ross
we'll be tracking Fiona as the storm
makes its way up the Atlantic coast over
the next few days and checking in with
global news meteorologist Anthony
Farnell for any updates so Anthony
what's the latest on the storm's
movements
me too Fiona is already a large and
dangerous storm but it's going to get
even bigger in size as it approaches
Atlantic Canada here's Bermuda under a
hurricane warning right now and the eyes
still very distinct but what's going to
happen over the course of the next day
this hurricane combines with a front
with a trough just off the east coast
and it's that hybrid nature that we
haven't seen since hurricane Sandy made
landfall in the Mid-Atlantic causing all
sorts of Destruction this is our version
the Canadian version of Sandy of course
there's less population in this area but
power outages incredible waves storm
surge and the fresh water flooding from
rainfall Let's just look at the waves
for example by late Friday into Saturday
morning during high tide just off the
coast of Cape Breton we could see 12 to
14 meter waves that is going to cause
incredible erosion and flooding as well
now the syst system because of the angle
it's taking this doesn't happen very
often so trees are susceptible they're
still in full foliage we're going to see
power outages that likely last days if
not weeks and of course we have not just
tropical storm and hurricane watches
rainfall warnings for up to 200
millimeters there's a lot of weather
going on and this is just the beginning
as landfall doesn't occur until early
Saturday morning
all right Global News meteorologist
Anthony Farnell thanks Anthony
there is a growing Exodus of Russian men
fleeing the country following Vladimir
Putin's order to mobilize 300 000
reservists to fight in Ukraine according
to the Finnish Border guard there's been
a noticeable increase in traffic at The
Crossings between the two countries with
more than 4 800 Russians Crossing
yesterday up from about 3 000 on a
normal day and this is the scene along
one of Russia's Southern borders with a
huge lineup to make the crossing into
Georgia's Breakaway region of South
osetia
there is also new footage of the largest
prisoner swap between Ukraine and Russia
in the war so far more than 200
Ukrainian prisoners were released Russia
got 55 soldiers back including a close
Ally of President Putin as those Russian
soldiers prepare to return home Redmond
Shannon reports on thousands of other
panicked men now fleeing before they're
drafted into the war
walking out from the darkness after
months as prisoners of War more than 200
Ukrainian troops are now back on home
soil
money from the azov Battalion soldiers
who surrendered in May
after weeks holed up in the as of style
steel plant as part of the brokered
prisoner swap there released commanders
will have to stay in Turkey until the
end of the war
we are proud of you President Vladimir
zielinski told them 10 foreigners who
fought for Ukraine were also freed with
the help of Saudi negotiators
I just want to say I want to thank
everyone especially selinski and the
Saudis and
everyone I was involved in exchange
Russia got back just 55 soldiers along
with the prize of Victor medvechuk a
pro-russian Ukrainian politician and
oligarch who was facing charges of
treason in Ukraine
alongside the reunions there are
separations to the kremlin's
mobilization of reservists already
underway
Reports say anti-mobilization protesters
have been drafted to even those without
military experience
men trying to escape the draft face long
weights or Hefty airfares mobilization
is one of the reasons why I'm here the
war's two alternate realities on display
again at the UN General Assembly
both sides accusing each other of lies
and war crimes Russian diplomats are
directly complicit because their lies
inside these crimes
and cover them up so despite this week's
prisoner swap hope of any War mediation
seems further away than ever Redmond
Shannon Global News London
coming up a little later Eric Sorensen
takes a deeper look at Russia's war
strategy and how plans to Stage
referendums could lay the groundwork for
control of key Ukrainian territory first
though prime minister Justin Trudeau has
agreed to scrap Canada's covid-19
vaccine mandate at the border and make
the arrive can app optional a senior
government Source tells Global News the
decision was made today but plans still
need to be finalized the federal
government is still considering whether
to maintain masking requirements for
planes and trains the Prime Minister
returned to work in Ottawa today Trudeau
sparred with Pierre pauliev in the first
question period since the conservative
leadership race as David Aiken reports a
few shots were fired as the two leaders
pressed each other on inflation and the
rising cost of living
The Honorable leader of the opposition
it started out graciously enough the
Prime Minister speaking French wish
Pierre qualiev congratulations on his
new job but then it was down to business
a fight over carbon taxes the leader of
the liberal party has an opportunity to
respect the fact that heating your home
in January and February in Canada is not
a luxury and it is does not make those
Canadians polluters they're just trying
to survive this the Prime Minister
pointed to his just announced plan to
double the GST rebate top up a housing
benefit and help give kids in low-income
homes money for dental care
on this side of the house we're going to
continue to stay focused on direct and
real help for Canadians ristruto gotta
dig in about pauliev's comment during
the leadership campaign that
cryptocurrency was a good hedge against
inflation if Canadians had followed the
advice of the leader of the opposition
and invested in volatile
cryptocurrencies in attempt to quote opt
out of inflation they would have lost
half of their savings well pauliev
suggested Trudeau was an out of touched
Jet Set from a prime minister who burned
more jet fuel in one month than 20
average Canadians burn in an entire year
now speaking of jets Global News can
report there will soon be some big news
on the Travel front the Prime Minister
has signed off on a plan to end the
mandatory use of the arrive can app for
cross-border travelers other health
restrictions including vaccine
requirements are likely to expire
September 30th the rules on mask wearing
May remain in place expect a formal
announcement on these changes Monday
need to David Aiken reporting tonight
thanks David
the federal government is launching a
long-awaited review to determine how
legalizing marijuana has affected
Canadians
the review will help ensure that the ACT
adapts to the current situation and
continues to meet Canadians needs and
expectations
the liberal government
you cannabis near
ER years ago with the provision it would
review the law three years later the
Cannabis act review is almost a year
overdue it will look at several areas
including the impact on indigenous
people the health of Canadians and the
black market
shocking secrecy in Ontario's child
welfare system coming up the critical
information The Province isn't sharing
with the public
plus the incredible new image of our
farthest planet courtesy of the James
Webb Telescope
for the past year Global News has been
investigating the state of the child
welfare system in Ontario tonight we
have a shocking Discovery to share with
you for years the province has
identified what it calls high-risk
foster care and group homes but it isn't
sharing the information with the public
or Children's Aid societies the
organizations responsible for placing
kids in care our Carolyn Jarvis is part
of the investigative team behind this
project Carolyn
nithu we've learned that the Ontario
government has a small but specialized
team of investigators which identifies
potentially problematic foster care and
group homes and then conducts
unannounced inspections that part
experts in the field are praising but
here's the rub the ministry isn't
sharing the names of those homes with
Children's Aid societies nor indigenous
agencies who may have kids there if
you're a young person going to live in a
group home let's say
shouldn't you know that there's concerns
about the home and what those are before
you go there shouldn't your parents or
your caregivers or legal Guardians know
about what those concerns are since the
specialized team was formed in 2017 15
foster care agencies and group home
operators in Ontario have come under its
watch we were able to obtain their names
through a freedom of information request
and have posted them on our website at
globalnews.ca as well as responses from
all of the companies the government
meanwhile wouldn't explain to us why it
won't make the names public and the
documents we obtained don't explain why
a specific operator was deemed high risk
we reported on some of the group homes
on that list in the past homes where
kids say they were neglected physically
restrained without justification and
where some kids have even died which is
why current and former Children's Aid
directors say it is vital that if the
province knows a home is potentially
problematic the public needs to know as
well
me too Carolyn Jarvis in Toronto thanks
Carolyn and as Carolyn mentioned you can
read the complete investigation the
latest in our child welfare series on
our website globalnews.ca global
national
the Royal Canadian Mint has unveiled a
new Keepsake coin representing the truth
of the residential school system the
artwork on the coins created in
partnership with the national Center For
Truth and Reconciliation is an
expression of indigenous culture with
one side showing a combination of First
Nations Inuit and metis designs and the
other bearing orange handprints and the
words every child matters in English and
in French with net proceeds going to an
nctr Community healing fund the coins
are also meant to educate Canadians and
Spark conversations about the impacts of
the institutions of assimilation while
instilling a commitment to
reconciliation across the country
I had violent protests spiral in Iran
over the death of a young woman
the Ukrainian military says it is
gaining ground against Russian troops in
key areas of luhansk it's still one of
four russian-controlled territory set to
hold a referendum on joining Russia
Ukraine and its allies say the votes are
rigged as Eric Sorensen reports they're
part of Putin's wider strategy to gain
crucial ground and justify his reasoning
in luhansk in eastern Ukraine Russian
colors and flags are everywhere this
billboard promotes a United Russia much
of the ethnic Russian population in this
war-torn area supports a referendum to
join Russia
we need Russia's protection says this
man speaking Russian
my generation was brought up in the
Soviet Union she says we need to unite
again but in zapparicia strong Ukrainian
Defiance toward Russia calling the
referendum illegitimate absolutely a
so-called referendum he says is being
forced from the outside against the will
of the people
the referendum he says is fake to show
occupied territories want to join Russia
fake or not many believe Russian
installed officials will declare all the
results in favor of joining Russia the
results of the those uh those
referendums are predetermined you know
the majority of the people in there will
it'll be reported that they support
joining Russia that is far from the
truth Russia is backing referendums in
luhansk and Donetsk and in zapparesia
and Carson but it is also here where
Russian forces are in control are trying
to control eastern Ukraine now Ukrainian
forces to back kharkiv but it is in
these four provinces where Russia
appears to be trying to consolidate both
a military grip and now a political grip
that would seamlessly connect Russia to
Crimea and in Russia's view it would
turn this fight in the region from an
attack on Ukraine to a defense of Russia
President Vladimir Putin has now
threatened to use nuclear weapons to
defend what he deems Russian territory
and justify the mobilization of more
Russian forces he has been losing
so now he is using this mobilization and
also the referenda Russia then can
pretend that any attempt to liberate
these Ukrainian territories would be a
direct attack on Russia itself the U.S
says Russia's actions will not stop the
fight inside those territories no
Russian claim to Annex territory can
take away Ukraine's right to defend its
own land in effect Washington and NATO
are calling Putin's Bluff but when
Russia says it will defend itself with
nuclear weapons it is a high stakes
Bluff for both sides Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
another high-profile Ally of Vladimir
Putin has died under suspicious
circumstances Russian State media says
Anatoly garishenko died after falling
down several flights of stairs
garashenko was the former head of a
Russian Aviation research University and
an important figure in the Russian
defense establishment since the invasion
of Ukraine began nearly a dozen
high-ranking Russians with close ties to
the Kremlin have died in what are said
to be accidents or apparent suicides
at least a dozen people have now been
killed during growing protests in Iran
following the death of a young woman
while in the custody of the country's
morality police
the protests have spread to more than 80
towns and cities with the anger focused
on the country's fundamentalist regime
and its police and Security Services
last Friday 22 year old Masa amini died
after being arrested in Tehran accused
of not wearing a headscarf as part of
the Crackdown the Iranian government has
shut down most of the country's mobile
networks and blocked access to social
media services and the internet
next no lost love two estranged Brothers
in Ontario go head to head in a race for
mayor
the James Webb Space Telescope keeps
delivering its newest image released by
NASA shows our Solar System's farthest
planet in a whole new light the infrared
image of Neptune captures the clearest
view of the planet's rings in more than
30 years the crisp pitcher also shows
thin lines of light around the icy giant
NASA says their methane ice clouds
reflecting the sun seven of Neptune's 14
known moons are also clearly visible the
biggest is Triton which appears brighter
than Neptune itself the planet's rings
have not been detected since NASA's
Voyager 2 became the first spacecraft to
observe Neptune during a flyby in 1989.
NASA says today's tests were successful
Paving the way to a green light for the
launch of its Artemis 1 rocket two
earlier launches for the moon mission
were scrubbed over concerns about a fuel
leak the next scheduled launch window is
September 27th the unmanned Artemis 1
Mission will be a test of the rocket and
capsule designed to return people to the
moon in 2025.
it is a sibling rivalry unlike anything
seen before in Port Colburn Ontario the
Lake Erie town south of Niagara Falls
has become a focal point during this
municipal election cycle and a pair of
brothers is to thank for the attention
because both of them are running for the
same mayoral seat and as Mike drolets
their family tie is where their
similarities end
You could argue Port Colburn wouldn't
exist on the North shore of Lake Erie if
not for the Welland Canal
which connects Lake Ontario to the rest
of the Great Lakes
the town now a city was incorporated in
the 1830s but its roots are made of
steel yeah a lot of Rich history here a
lot of Rich history this is Bill Steele
one of the descendants of William Steele
a farmer and Loyalist to the king of
England forced to flee North during the
American Revolution in the 1770s today
Bill like his great uncle and
great-grandfather before him serves as
the mayor and he would have been a claim
for another term if not for Charles
Steele I decided to run for mayor when I
realized that nobody else wanted to run
what makes this race such a curiosity is
this Oddity the two men fighting for the
big seat are brothers
as long as they can sit down and have
supper together after they haven't
spoken in 30 years well then that could
create some challenges I'm sure that's
right no communication for three decades
running an underdog campaign Charles
didn't even let his brother know he was
ready to challenge him so far they're
keeping things clean focusing on issues
like affordable housing and water and
not their estrangement is there any
reason why
just have different uh viewpoints on
politics and life and things like that
you can't exactly fault bill for failing
to see his brother coming Charles is
going by his given name on the ballot
even though everyone who knows him here
has always called him by his middle name
David if you were in a debate
would you refer to him as David
that's his name
that's a bit of a jab but
I'm not really bothered by it and that's
good because what politics can get nasty
nothing compares to Sibling Rivalry
micro Lake Global News Port Colburn
Ontario
and that is global national for this
Thursday night I'm nitu Garcia tonight's
your Canada celebrating the heroes of
the 1972 Summit Series
today members of parliament welcomed
several players from Team Canada who
defeated the Soviets in the legendary
final game 50 years ago today one of the
most iconic moments in Canadian hockey
history thanks for watching Jeff Semple
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]
foreign